السفينه السعوديه امانه تصل الى جده وعلى
متنها
1762 شخصا تم اجلائهم من السودان وهذه
الصور المباشره لوصول السفينه السعوديه
امانه الى جده ونعود ونذكر بانه على متنها
1762 شخصا تم اجلائهم من السودان طبعا هذه
العمليات منذ اكثر من اسبوع من بورتسودان
الى جده
رحلات عديده وسفن عديده وصلت الى جده الى
اكثر من الى الميناء وايضا الى
المطارات في السعوديه التي اجلت العديد من
الرعايه ان كان من
الدول الغربيه او الدول العربيه
وقامت السعوديه بجهود كبيره وجباره خلال
عمليات الاجلاء حيث تمت هذه الرحلات
بسلاسه من بورت سودان الى القواعد الجويه
او الى امينه جده
اذا نتابع سويا وصول السفينه امانه الى
جده والتي تحمل
1762 شخصا تم اجلائهم من السودان وكانت
سفن عديده ايضا وصلت الى هذا الميناء تحمل
على متنها الالاف من الرعايه الاجانب
والعرب
وطبعا تم تامين مسكنهم حتى وقت مغادرتهم
الى
بلادهم امنت لهم فيز محدوده طبعا حتى
يتمكنوا من الدخول الى السعوديه ومن ثم
الى مغادره
مغادرتهم الى بلادهم
الالاف من
اليمنيين والسوريين واللبنانيين
والجزائريين
والمغاربه يعني من كل الجنسيات تاكلها
وصلت الى القاعده الجويه في السعوديه
وايضا الى ميناء جده حيث كانت تتم عمليات
الاجلاء من بورسودان الى جده
اذا ما زلنا نتابع وصول هذه السفينه
ودائما من خلال تاطيتنا لكل هذه الايام
لدى وصول
السفن الى جده دائما تكون كل القطاعات
موجوده عند وصول هذه السفن وخاصه
الهيئات الصحيه في حال كان هناك اي شخص
مريض او اي شخص مرهق من التعب فدائما يتم
معاينتهم ويتم الاهتمام بهم طبعا
الاليه هي بعد ما ينزلون من هذه السفن
يتوجهون طبعا الى اماكن تخليص المعاملات
والاوراق ومعظم الاحيان يكون هناك ممثلين
عن قناصل هذه الدول او بعض المنظمات ايضا
تكون متواجدا ومن ثم يتم نقلهم
بالبساطه الى اماكن سكنهم ومن ثم طبعا
يغادرون الى بلادهم اذا اكثر تقريبا من من
عشره الاف شخص خلال هذه العمليه عمليات
الاجلاء قد خرجت من السودان
ووصلت من بورتسودان حقيقه ووصلت الى جده
وخاصه هذا الميناء اهلا بك اهلا بكافه
مشاهدي قناه العربيه بالفعل وصلت الان
سفينه امانه وهي الرحله الثالثه لهذه
السفينه التجاريه المدنيه السعوديه وتحمل
اعداد كبيره من الرعايه بعد ان تم اجلائهم
من ميناء بورت سوداني لقاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه او بجده وعلى متنها
1762 راكبا من ثلاثا 33 جنسيه تعدت
الجنسيات واختلفت من ضمنهم 81 امريكي
نتحدث عن 19 من الجنسيه المصريه وكذلك
نتحدث عن وجود ثلاثه المان وايضا اعداد
كبيره لهؤلاء الرعايه على سبيل المثال
وجود اثنين من البرازيل وكذلك من الفلبين
واذربيجان وسريلانكا وجزر القمر وباكستان
وايضا الدنمارك والكاميرون والصومال
والسويد والسويسرا والقائمه تطول ممن تمت
اجلائهم من ميناء بورت السودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده وهذه الرحله
البحريه الثامنه عشره التي تصل الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه من ضمنها خمسه عشر
رحله سفينه التابعه للقوات البحريه
السعوديه وثلاثه بهذه الرحله تكون الثامنه
عشره نتحدث عن ثلاثه رحلات مدنيه وهذه هي
الرحله الثالثه تصل الان وعلى متنها كما
ذكرنا اعداد كبيره من الرعايه
وكما هو بيان وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
تتحدث عن اجلاء اكثر من سته الاف مواطن من
جنسيات وصلوا الى ارض السعوديه قادمين الى
قاعده الملك فيصل وكذلك عبر ايلا قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه وايضا الى ميناء
جده الاسلامي كافه الرحلات البحريه
والجويه هي قادمه من مدينه بورسودان من
مطار بورت سودان تحديدا ومن قاعده ومن
ميناء بورتسودا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات